[Music]
on this sunday night
ontario's 28-day lockdown
the province's tough measures to get
coveted 19 numbers
down we will see in all likelihood
a moment of historic difficulty in the
month of january
the circuit breaker and its impact on
schools and businesses
a new strain of the virus forces
european countries to ban
uk travel the new variant is out of
control and we need to bring it
under control will canada follow suit a
first nations community returns home
it's not clean enough to drink why a
water advisory is still in place
and the break dancing breakout
the new sport at the 2024 olympics
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us global news has learned ontario will
implement sweeping measures that will
put that province into a lockdown
for almost a month and here's why today
ontario reported more than 2300 new
infections and
25 more deaths it's the sixth
consecutive day the province has
registered more than 2
000 new cases the caseload is putting
pressure on hospitals
and as morgan campbell reports the
ontario government hopes
this circuit breaker will break the
chain of transmission
this holiday rush at the mall may be the
last indoor gathering
in ontario for now and it is as if
people in this province
expect it put it this way it's awful
for not follow what they ask global news
has learned ontario will be completely
locked down
for 28 days come christmas eve sources
close to the premier's office say the
only exception
will be in northern communities which
will be placed under
a 14-day lockdown period the move comes
at a time the province grapples with
record-high new cases of the novel
coronavirus
what we're seeing is all over the world
leaders are now sort of
rethinking the christmas holiday and how
we're going to position ourselves for it
you know they may have reasons for their
secrecy but look i'm going to say this
you know the lack of transparency erodes
trust
there will be an impact on schools come
the new year
elementary students will not return to
class but will spend the first week of
school
in learning from home high schools will
remain closed for the entire lockdown
period
sources tell global news the premier
calls it a circuit breaker
and it will also require all
nonessential businesses
to shutter across the province and
restrictions could be placed on
outdoor activities such as skiing and
skating medical experts believe stricter
measures are needed to curb the spread
of the virus
probably fines are what's needed if the
threat of
you know if reason doesn't work maybe
then enforcement
is something the reality is if no one
ever left their house again
there would be no transmission so we
know
we know logically that that works the
problem is what is going to be
the downstream effects of that the
measures are in line with what the
ontario hospital association has been
calling for to ensure that hospitals do
not
face a devastating surge in covet 19
patients
we see that rejected by too many people
we will see
in all likelihood a moment of historic
difficulty in the month of january
meanwhile global news has learned that
the premier
and his cabinet were considering asking
for the provincial
shutdown of all airports and to
implement a province-wide curfew
in the end those ideas were rejected
morgan campbell global news toronto
we are also learning that the federal
government is restricting travel from
the u.k as of midnight tonight
it's a move to stop the spread of a fast
spreading variant of the novel
coronavirus
it was first reported in england last
week at least six european nations
including france and germany have
already slapped temporary bans on travel
to and from britain
here's ross lord in contrast to these
scenes
people rushing into train stations to
get out of town
day one of the london lockdown was
marked by emptiness
streets abandoned as new rules take
effect restricting the movement of more
than 16 million people
i think they're very quite brutal but i
think
it's to be expected i think it's what's
needed because everyone's made plans and
because it's
this close to christmas and then we're
being told it's it's being cancelled i
think that's made it a lot more
difficult
a growing number of european union
governments are banning travel from the
uk
all because of the new variant of the
novel coronavirus
the new variant is out of control and we
need to bring it
under control the new measures follow
reports the mutation transmits up to 70
percent more than existing strains
a frightening number but some infectious
disease specialists in canada
are not convinced the key questions are
is this more transmissible
does this cause of perhaps a more severe
illness and will the vaccine work on
this strain
and quite frankly none of those answers
or none of those questions have
definitive answers
doctors say it's likely covert 19
vaccines will be effective against the
variant
ross lord global news the united states
is concerned about an explosion of cases
from holiday travel just look at what
happened after thanksgiving
the kova 19 death toll is fast
approaching 320 000
in the u.s today trucks began delivering
the delicate doses of moderna vaccine
but as jennifer johnson reports
hospitals are still preparing for an
overwhelming caseload in january
workers cheer as hundreds of boxes of
the moderna vaccine are loaded onto
delivery trucks
one ups truck driven by todd elbel who
lost his 78 year old father to covet 19.
i couldn't think of a better honor to do
for my father
than to do this today millions of doses
left the company's mississippi plant
found for hospitals and pharmacies
across the country there is light
at the end of the tunnel there are now
two vaccines that are approved they are
incredibly effective unifications the
trump administration's operation warp
speed is on track to deliver six million
moderna doses
to 3 700 sites in every state this week
and another 2 million doses of the
pfizer biontech vaccine
we started slow we're going to continue
to increase so
the american people should be hopeful
about vaccines but we also need to
remain vigilant
health officials are predicting the
covet 19 death toll will keep rising
dramatically after the christmas holiday
travelers and celebrations causing
another deadly surge
it does seem to be the case that we're
on track probably to peak in terms of
the number of infections somewhere
around the first week in january as
federal officials try to speed up
vaccination rates
millions of nursing home residents are
facing delays as officials struggle to
get consent forms signed
especially for those with dementia and
alzheimer's meanwhile anxious americans
awaiting financial help from congress
are getting good news
late saturday the senate agreed to a
coronavirus aid package
giving extra money to most taxpayers the
unemployed and businesses struggling to
pay their bills
the great news is congress is not going
to be the grinch we're going to get this
package done
u.s president donald trump is expected
to sign the bill monday
five days before unemployment benefits
were set to expire
for 12 million americans jennifer
johnson
global news washington none of it has
reported the territory's first two
coronavirus deaths
a residence from arvia died yesterday
after developing complications related
to the virus
a rank an inland resident also died
yesterday after contracting the virus in
southern canada
it wasn't until november 6 that none of
it reported its first confirmed covet 19
case it has since infected more than 200
people
across the territory a remote indigenous
community in northern ontario has
welcomed back
its residents two months ago members of
the neshkandaga first nation were forced
to leave over water concerns
about 250 residents were transported
from the fly-in community to thunder bay
where they were put up in hotels more
work needs to be done to repair the
local water treatment facility
and people there will still need to
drink bottled water
but it's an issue that has persisted for
more than 25 years
and as david aiken reports the community
wants to know why it's taking decades
to fix the problem
[Music]
an emotional day for the nishkanaga
first nation
really happy very happy and glad to be
home
pleasure that christmas is here and we
need to be home
evacuated in october the community is
back
after spending 60 days living in thunder
bay
450 kilometers away here you go
and even though upgrades to the
community's water treatment plant is
now producing water free of
disease-causing bacteria
the boil water advisory remains in place
because of continued deficiencies in the
plant and distribution system
it's not clean enough to drink i just
got the reported the
the test and uh boiled water
advisory is still recommended but it is
we are getting very close to uh
getting that lifted hopefully that will
happen next year
and so nishkanika continues to rely on
boxes of
bottled water shipped in to this fly-in
community
we're just gonna have to go with it i
guess
until we until the
we're told that it's okay to drink but
the frustration
remains i can only be as patient
as i can i'm very frustrated
and you know i just
i don't know sometimes like i just feel
like losing hope
like what's the point like are we
supposed to live like this our whole
lives is that what they expect of us
why did it take a quarter century to fix
it
or longer you know why
what does that say about our country i
mean i
you know do i mean this is something
that uh you know that needs to be fixed
and even when this 25-year long boil
water advisory is lifted
there will be a new problem convincing
people that their tap water is
safe if we're able to get clean water
here
i'm still not going to trust myself to
drink the tap water because
i've been growing up drinking water
bottles and stuff like that
david aiken global news ottawa
coming up canada's other health
emergency the opioid crisis
2020 has been a deadly year for the
opioid crisis particularly in western
canada
every month bc's coroner's service makes
overdose data
public now alberta says it will do the
same launching a new online tool
this year alone the two provinces have
recorded more than 2 300
overdose deaths global national's
heather york's west reports
canada's opioid crisis has killed
thousands of people since 2016.
but in alberta 2020 is proving to be the
deadliest year
so far we are in unchartered water when
it comes to overdose we have never
lost as many people to overdose between
january and october more than 1 000
people in alberta died from drug
poisonings
904 of those deaths were related to
fentanyl
that's more deaths than any other year
since the opioid crisis began
alberta's premier believes policies
aimed at reducing the spread of covet 19
are to blame the government suspended
the operation of residential
treatment centers and then reduced the
number
of people who could stay within them
and also suspended the operation of
opioid dependency clinics
in alberta these programs reopened in
april after a brief shutdown in march
but alberta's overdose deaths actually
peaked in july
likely because of an increasingly toxic
illegal drug supply
when we look internationally the un
office of drugs and
crime has looked at this issue they are
reporting that border closures
have led to significant disruptions in
illegal drug markets
and as a result drug markets have become
much more volatile
during coven alberta is not the only
jurisdiction seeing a rise in overdose
deaths
bc has seen a record number of deaths
this year as well
but while b.c has looked at expanding
access to a safe drug supply alberta's
government is focusing instead on
treatment and recovery
eliminating fees for residential
treatment beds but pulling funding for
the opioid replacement program
susan tierney's son has come to depend
on i also believe
that the program the harm reduction
programs
that they're trying to shot down
is not a good thing they need they need
all
different avenues for the recovery and
that
is one of one of them alberta officials
are now promising to update overdose
data
every month with two weeks to go 2020
already proving
to be a deadly year for those struggling
with addiction
heather urex west global news calgary
there's a new hotline in canada to help
in case of an overdose
the national overdose response service
is staffed by volunteers who have
first-hand experience
the number can be reached 24-7
still ahead no country left behind the
calls for equal access to the vaccine
a thirteen-year-old boy in nigeria is
sharing details of the nightmare he
endured when he was kidnapped from his
school
the teenager was one of more than 340
boys taken by armed men
on december 11th he was reunited with
his family last
week the terror group boko haram claimed
responsibility saying jihadists targeted
the school because they believe
western education is un-islamic but
police say local bandits wanting money
were behind the abduction
there was another attempted kidnapping
in the same area of nigeria
last night gunmen abducted more than 80
students but police say they were
returned by security forces
after a fierce gun battle even before
there was a covet-19 vaccine there were
fears supplies would get snapped up by
richer nations
now that science has delivered there are
calls to make sure developing countries
get those crucial doses but as reggie
jacini explains
it's far from a fair share of this
globally funded medicine
the loss and devastation felt in 2020 is
breathtaking
kovitt 19 ravaged lives and economies on
a global scale
but returning to a semblance of normal
has its own obstacles
one of the biggest threats to preventing
this pandemic coming to an end
is what's become called vaccine
nationalism rich nations
provided billions of dollars to back
vaccine research and wanted to guarantee
a return on investment
in just a few minutes i'll sign an
executive order
earlier this month president trump
called for all americans to be first in
line
it was largely symbolic but the message
showcases how wealth plays into this
pandemic
the pandemic is global and the response
has to be global
to ensure vaccine distribution is
equitable the world health organization
and two non-profits backed by the gates
foundation
launched kovacs it funded some vaccine
candidates
and was promised hundreds of millions of
doses in return
an arduous effort to get 1 billion doses
to 92 poor nations
now the program is primarily about
rationing better it's far from what's
needed good enough for maybe twenty
percent of that population
and it doesn't provide a way for poorer
countries to get access to vaccine
innovation
we can afford to pay for the technology
that will end the pandemic
what we can't afford is excellence
exclusivity and secrecy
limiting the available supply some
nonprofits like oxfam are critical of
countries buying their way to protection
and using power as a bargaining chip
we've seen
already certain nations that want to
extend their chess board
of geopolitics use vaccine diplomacy to
try to get in the good graces of
countries that can't get access to
vaccines as
vaccine production ramps up so too do
purchases
several countries including canada have
procured more doses than they need
ottawa along with the eu have signaled
they may donate unused doses to kovacs
the u.s is not a part of the program
after president trump
withdrew from the who the more that the
rich world locks up the supply
the harder it's going to be for kovacs
to get enough doses
to go to low and middle income countries
the global community relied on each
other to slow the spread of covet 19.
now health experts are cautioning
without that same effort to eradicate it
far too many will be left behind or lost
reggie shaking global news washington
up next the bold move that has brought a
new competition
to the olympics
the international olympic committee has
declared break dancing its newest
official sport
it'll debut at the 2024 paris games
it's an effort to appeal to younger
audiences and as michael couture
explains
the canadian dance community believes
its high time
breaking was on the world stage
it's known as break dancing breaking
b-boying or b-girling but as of the
paris summer 2024 games
it'll officially be known as an olympic
sport
including the athletic street dance is a
clear example of the international
olympic committee's goal
to broaden the appeal of the games here
we have
had a clear priority and this was to
introduce
sports which are in particular popular
among the younger generations and it
follows the patterns set for the tokyo
games which will see the debut of
surfing
skateboarding and sport climbing next
year it makes sense
it makes complete sense brian tong has
been dancing for decades he challenges
anyone who thinks that breaking
isn't worthy of the olympics people
think that you just jump in and do
these one two step but really there's
lots of calisthenics work out that
requires a lot of strength within
breakdancing
and when new sports are added others
have to be removed
so in 2024 both boxing and weightlifting
will be paired down both have trouble
governing bodies and both are practiced
predominantly by men which makes it an
easy choice for the ioc
as it works towards gender balance in
the games
maybe there's consideration that if we
do
more diverse more diversity in our
sports
younger target audiences and more
accessibility
we we might get greater uptake by women
athletes
a breaking in how to score and judge it
was hotly debated at the 2018 youth
olympics in argentina
because it's not like gymnastics there
are some purists in the breaking
community
who worry putting the art form on a
world stage could move it further from
its urban roots
many believe it can be like snowboarding
which didn't sell out
just to be part of the games they're not
approaching it to be
accepted by the olympics we are
hoping that the olympics will take us in
for what we are
and people will be able to see what it
is and be able to see that breaking
truly fits the olympic motto
of faster higher stronger mike lacrouter
global news ottawa
and that is global national for this
sunday i'm robin gill we leave you
tonight with santa swimming with the
fish
the vancouver aquarium held its annual
scuba claws
despite being closed the show went
virtual on social media ensuring saint
nick can keep spreading holiday cheer
underwater thank you for watching i'll
see you back here tomorrow have a great
[Music]
night
you